[Music]  your minds in the church house I think  he's waiting for you come to confess  your sins no no how much time you got  more than you have you been juicing  little vibranium cocktail you're looking  I don't want to say puffy  you're stalling to protect the people  that is the mission you forget I've  moved beyond your mission I'm free  what do you think you were the only ones  darling there's the rest of the  vibranium function still monkey this is  how you end Tony this is peace in my  time  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  my vision they really didn't take  everything from me  you set the tum so you can change them  all right  [Music]  [Music]  Freddie division boss it's working he's  burning Ultron out of the net he won't  escape through there you shut me out  you think I care music with my world I  take away yours  you